i saw that photo you just posted with ll
cool j oh my god
what did it mean to see him here tonight
you know what like i've been very very
fortunate
in a in a 20-plus year career to do a
lot of beautiful things and a lot of
things that i'm very very grateful for
um
i was able to do super bowl twice i've
done the grammys i've done a lot of
things so i don't get nervous i get
anxious but i don't get nervous
the only time i've ever been nervous i
did
vh1 hip-hop honors and i had a chance to
celebrate ll cool j
and if you look at those things i came
out on a riser
and backstage before i went out on the
riser
ll comes up to me because i'm doing ll
we're celebrating l
and he comes up and he says yo make me
look good baby
and i went white it's just like i've
never been nervous in my life now i'm
like
holy that's the man that he's that
that's
yo he missed so much like he's he's
definitely a goat what he meant to
hip-hop i don't think hip-hop is in a
place
without him that it is without elle cool
james getting the rock and a hall of
fame this year so deserved
elton john getting the icon oh my other
goat my other girl my other g
are you kidding me yeah you know we were
just backstage rapping and the fact that
he knew
the last time that we met each other and
i was wrong
i was wrong did you he corrected me i
was wrong because i
i said the meeting beforehand and he
said the literal last meeting
he even told me the car i was driving
when it happened and that was like
huge like elton come on man that's like
what does that mean to you that he knows
that but he remembered that
are you serious like it's john hey
just be for real exactly all right that
says it all
um you are gonna go and perform live
again soon right yes how excited are you
to do
that what can we expect uh very grateful
um again
um this job is what it is and we do a
lot
i will never complain about being on the
road again ever in life
you know because you you don't truly
understand not just what it means to you
professionally but what it means to you
personally
because it's an outlet and everything
allows you to be who you
are and if you take any element away
something has to suffer and i figured
out
what being on the road and connecting
with my fans really means to me being
able to connect with my family
and how those two relationships exactly
exactly
you know what i mean because it is
everything is everything
and you need that joy everything is
everything all right are we gonna get
some new music from you soon
definitely i have a new project called
the heartland project uh my first single
out right now is featuring florida
georgia line you guys are so good
together
zach thank you so much i don't call it
uh some people call it a country i don't
call it a country album i say it's
country influenced
it's still a nelly album but um it's
definitely my appreciation
for how country music has allowed me to
be in their world how country music
from the artists to the fans to just the
whole genre has opened their arms to
nelly
this is my thank you this project and i
can't wait for everybody to hear it all
right well i'll let you go but let real
quick who do you still want to collab
with who's still on the list
collab with uh just speaking
specifically
in the in the format of what i'm doing
for the heartland project
hank williams so hank if you're out
there hank
call your boy you know what i'm saying
i'll get to elton later
like i would love elton john but hank
williams definitely
okay hey ellen remembers the car you
were driving well i'm throwing all of
them out there
so if you got any pool by all means let
me know
i'm not going to take it for granted so
good to see you thank you so much so
good to see you